I'm not from an I.T background
I'm an academician I have a doctorate
degree in electronics so when I started
creation Technologies in 2018 I was
learning by myself
the devops course that I took from
Simply learn helped me boost my business
and earnings by 40 hi I'm Ravi Kumar
chintalapudi and I am from visakhapatnam
I've never done a full-time job and
never worked from an I.T company from
doing my PhD to freelancing to starting
my own business this is what my
professional Journey looks like
my passion has always been Computing so
while I was doing my PhD I started
freelancing I started providing cloud
services server management and database
migration to my clients
I built my clientele around the world
and I became a full-time freelancer
after I finished my PhD my friends saw
the business potential and that is how
gradient Technologies were started
things were working out well for us and
then in 2020 we decided to expand our
business services based on devops tools
we already had clients coming to us with
requirements of end-to-end devops
automation but to do so I needed to
learn devops since I am the one who is
providing services to the times and I
had no idea so I opted the pgp course
from Simply learn in association with
Caltech ctme it gave me confidence to
face my clients and ask for projects
based on devops we are now working with
five such clients and the revenue has
increased by 40 percent I was also able
to implement a full end-to-end devops
pipeline which I was not able to do so
initially I started learning devops by
myself but I needed a streamlined course
and simply learned provided that
whenever I had doubts the instructors
cleared them in online classes the
classes were on weekends and hence I was
able to spend time with my family I
worked from home so it's an added
advantage my long-term goal is to
provide an on-call available devops team
to my client and this course has given
me the confidence as well as I'm able to
guide the newcomers who join the company
it's great that courses like this are
helping businessmen like me to turn
their Vision into reality
[Music]